oh my God
nailed it
this guy is always trying to spoil a bad
thing
ah you guys are here too took the long
way huh is everything a joke to you why
must you constantly interfere with my
destiny because my destiny is to protect
my friends and family I think I just
threw up in my mouth
and if you want that Emerald you're
gonna have to go through me
[Music]
the Echidna is taking no prison today
Sonic has Hearts but will he lose the
quill to live
I don't want to fight you but you're not
giving me much choice
[Music]
ah too easy let's do this
and Die With Honor let me think about it
okay I thought about it
hi there beautiful
you're the real deal aren't you
Rita
say goodbye Hedgehog
[Music]
knuckle stop Robotnik stealing the
emerald what kind of fool do you take
before just look
wait that wasn't the deal
oh
poor naive creature it's not your fault
a more advanced intellect would have
seen this move coming a mile away or 1.6
kilometers
but I trusted you
you're my friend
I'm sorry that just hit me funny